this is russia's answer to covid19
sputnik v the first vaccine to be
registered globally
and now the first licensed vaccine to be
rolled out for wider distribution
this woman says it was quick and
pain-free
it's just moscow for now and just medics
teachers and social workers
dmitry buri works in a bank and he
wanted the jab
he's disappointed when he's turned away
why were you in such a rush to get the
vaccine
you're young and healthy
yesterday
foreign
mass vaccination needs a massive scaling
up of production
it won't be till next year that russia
can roll sputnik v out across the
country
and there are nine other vaccines in the
pipeline too
there's hardly a rush to get this
vaccine there are 70 polyclinics like
this one
across the russian capital where you can
sign up register
and then get the first of your two doses
of sputnik v
but today only 17 people signed up for
this particular clinic
patient light journalist heavy russia
has already vaccinated 60
000 people from at-risk groups beyond
the phase 3 trials
so today's pr moment looked a little
like an attempt to score another first
but with a record 28 000 cases across
russia in the last 24 hours
it's definitely needed
with all the major global vaccines
claiming a more than 90
success rate he is hoping that she's
right
diana magnay sky news moscow